Mr Speaker this morning I had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today
thank you Mr Speaker we're in the middle
of a housing crisis with mortgages
soaring rents rising and and house
building set to a post flow
and just last week with an interview
with the conservative home the Prime
Minister admitted his disastrous
decision to dropped housing targets to
appease Tory party members
house while the views of a thousand
members are more important to aspiring
homeowners families across the country
Mr Speaker on this side of the house we
believe in empowering local communities
the decisions that are right for them
and to protect their green spaces and
the place most acutely Warehouse
building is not keeping up with need is
in labor-controlled London
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker it's been reported
that the Welsh labor government is going
to incentivize people's Smugglers by
offering sixteen hundred pounds of
taxpayers money every month to Asylum
Seekers can I answer my right horrible
friend for an assurance that he will
never contemplate such a Daft idea in
our small boats though
well Mr Speaker I know my Noble friend
Lord Bellamy and the Secretary of State
for Wales wrote to the Welsh government
yesterday confirming that we would not
be undertaking their request now I know
that the labor leader has said that the
Welsh labor government is his blueprint
for migrants
Mr Speaker we're stopping the boats
Labor's paying for them
[Music]
[Applause]
the Tory party chair says that public
services are in pretty good shape
has the Prime Minister met a single
member of the public who agrees with him
Mr Mr Speaker Mr Speaker because of the
record investment that we're putting
into public services like the NHS we're
now getting waiting lists now because of
the reforms that we've made to our
education system more children are
studying in good and outstanding schools
because
he's living in another world to the rest
of us
people waiting more than two days from
an ambulance because they broke the NHS
only one 100 rapists going to court
system
a record number of small boats crossing
the channel because they broke the
Asylum system
people can't afford their bills can't
get the police to investigate crimes
can't get a doctor's appointment does
that really sound like pretty good shape
to him
[Applause]
2010 since since 2010 crime down by 50
under the conservative government
ministers 20 000 more police officers
and we've toughened up sentencing all
opposed by Sir softy over there
[Applause]
[Music]
I would considers want to win the
question and the answers what the one
says your progress questions beyond the
published once legal along with the
leader of the opposition help me to help
them yes Mr Speaker either the Prime
Minister doesn't use the same public
services to the rest of us or he simply
can't see the damage they've done to our
country
in 2019 Aria Lee a convicted people
Smuggler through boiling water over a
prison officer leaving him with
first-degree Burns
the prison officer said it felt like
acid his face was on fire
his attacker was found guilty received a
prison sentence quite right in my view
to the Prime Minister agree
Mr Speaker while record is clear on
sentencing it was this party and this
government that passed the sentencing
act last year
it toughened up sentences and the
average custodial sentence has now
increased since 2010 by almost
two-thirds for child sex abuse this is
up by 15 months and for rapists it's up
by two years and when our sentencing act
ended ended the automatic early release
of offenders who pose a danger to the
public it was a labor party who voted
against it
[Applause]
well look the problem is prime minister
arieli sentenced ariely's sentence ended
up being suspended yeah and anyone
watching this would wonder why someone
who violently attacks a key worker isn't
Behind Bars
well the court judgment spelled it out
cause it took 16 months for the attacker
to be charged that's ridiculous and it
took another two years before he was
sentenced completely unacceptable
caught the Prime Minister see that
because they've lost control of the
Court service because they've created
the largest Court backlog on record yes
he's letting violent criminals go free
Mr Speaker
record we're cracking down on grooming
gangs and
it's uncomfortable Mr Speaker he's
uncomfortable aggressive we toughen the
law on sex offenders so they spend
longer in prison he voted against it Mr
Speaker
we've increased rape convictions by over
60 percent meanwhile he meanwhile he he
attended he attended 21 sentencing
Council meetings that watered down
punishments
that's why they call him sir softy soft
on crime soft on criminals
[Applause]
[Music]
of sex offenders he's just shown he
doesn't understand how the criminal
justice system works no wonder he can't
fix it but and and he thinks that
cracking down on crime is suspending a
sentence where someone should be in
prison that shows the problem and
another reason Mr Speaker another reason
cited by the court for suspending the
sentence in ariali's case was a letter
from the Justice secretary in February
about prison overcrowding as a result of
that letter courts have been told to
have awareness of the impact of current
prison population levels when passing
sentences
in simple terms the Wrecking Ball the
Tories have taken to criminal justice
means that thousands of people who
should be in prison aren't yeah
the court also said he shakes his head
he should read the Judgment the court
also said that it's for the government
to say when prison conditions return to
a more normal state
now I know the Justice secretary has
been busy trying to save his own job
rather than actually doing it
but has the primers to ask him when he's
going to get a grip on the prison system
and withdraw that letter which is
allowing criminals to walk free
Mr Speaker we're in the process of
building 20 000 more prison places
that's all this government is delivering
because we're toughening up sentencing
and putting more people behind bars and
making sure that our most serious
offenders spend longer there but I I
love it when he talks about his record
as a lefty lawyer Mr Speaker because I
was looking I was looking at this
because when he was there I read easily
quoting things I read that people were
really disappointed that his
organization let down victims
if in my assessment that was his shadow
Attorney General
[Applause]
I want to get through these questions so
do my constituents if there's any
members constituency aren't interested
please leave the chairman well Mr
Speaker
when I was in office as director of
public prosecutions those benches
migrate to supporters in 2013 the home
Affairs select committee said uh we
would like to commend the work of the
director of public prosecutions Kia
stava he's striven to improve the
treatment of sexual assault they don't
want to say
foreign
questions matter to our constituents
I wonder if I were you it's not the day
I want to get through it because I'm
trying to help the Prime Minister and
the leader you're not being helpful
we'll hear this question number two how
long it takes okay Starbucks Mr Speaker
this is 2030 order
Miss Stevenson I've heard
I've heard a few weeks this the last
week I suggest you quiet or is better
you leave Mr Speaker this is the home
Affair Select Committee in 2013. they go
on to say the work I did should provide
a model to other agencies or when it
leaves the CPS he will be missed now
that report was presented to Parliament
via the then Home Secretary future Prime
Minister the rider remember for
maidenhead and the government those
pensions noted and supported it
now it's also always a good look to have
your work recognized although they did
lay it out a bit thick so perhaps
perhaps the primes have spent less time
trying to rewrite history of what I'm
sorting out the mess is made up for no
justice
crisis and
just a snap
of Public Services collapsing under his
wall
people can see it wherever they look our
room
trains
policing mental health Provisions the
Tories have broken them all and all
they've got left is excuses and blames
now I know the Prime Minister would
rather talk about a mass lesson than the
state of the country but perhaps it
could solve this equation why after 13
years of a Tory government are patients
waiting longer than ever criminals
walking free growth non-existent and why
everywhere you look just nothing seem to
work at all
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I I can't I can't
quite remember but I think he started by
talking about when he was DPP in 2013.
and I'm I'm actually I'm actually glad
he brought that out because there was
something else that happened when he was
DPP in 2013. all right and and that was
that was when he got his own special law
Mr Speaker I've got it right
here the pensions the pensions increase
it's that the pensions increased for
Kirsten
[Laughter]
can I just say it
I expect both sides to listen to the
questions and the answers prime minister
Mr Speaker here it is it's the the
pensions increase pension screen for
kirst armor QC 2013.
well we're well we're in choosing a
transformative policy to support doctors
doctors to cut the waiting list faster
he wants to raise taxes on public sector
workers and it's literally it's one law
for him and tax Rises for everyone else
[Applause]
don't let me double down on you please
tell the uncle
Mr Speaker recently I presented a prime
minister's point of light award to Joan
Willett nearly 1077 for her fundraising
for the British heart foundation and two
other Hastings and Rye residents Anthony
Kimber and Aleister felly were
celebrated as Community Champions at
number 10. will the Prime Minister join
me in thanking all our fantastic
volunteers and Community Champions not
only in Hastings and Rye but throughout
the United Kingdom and will he continue
to bring them together in Celebration
[Applause]
can I thank honorable friend and I'm
absolutely delighted that Joan received
her Points of Light award and volunteers
and Community Champions like Joan and
Anthony and Alistair all make important
contributions to their local community
and we're all very grateful to them in
fact every month Mr Speaker Millions do
the same thing and they deserve Our
Praise their generosity is integral to
what makes our country and our community
special and it's right that we do
everything we can to celebrate them they
do the SMP Stephen Flynn
[Applause]
[Music]
bring us away
[Applause]
as I've said I really do want to try and
help the person if you
if you do Stephen Flynn
because Mr
I'm delighted to hear that they had an
equally I'm delighted to hear that they
had an equally peaceful and relaxing
Easter break as I did
prime minister prime minister was it
their refusal to stand alongside
striking workers on the picket line
their acceptance of the economic damage
being caused by brexit or perhaps their
support for denying the people of
Scotland the right to choose their own
future which led to the leader of the
Scottish conservative party or during
voters to back labor
well Mr Mr Speaker
what we're doing it's not getting
distracted by the things that are going
on elsewhere and we're focused on
delivering for the people of Scotland
we're making sure that we fund Public
Services well with one and a half
billion extra pounds in Barnet
consequentials we're making sure that we
provide support with the cost of living
now I know Mr Speaker at the moment him
and his party are focused on other
matters
we're just gonna we're just gonna motor
on with the job
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker let me be clear we
will take no lechos no lectures from a
party which has not had a mandate to
govern in Scotland since 1955
in the course of just a matter of months
you cashed the economy who said mortgage
rates sorry you've taken energy support
away from families most in need now the
Prime Minister has been fined by the
police not once but twice but take
donations from russian-backed donors and
he of course have stuffed the house a
lot with people like baroness moon but
Mr Speaker let's be clear what we're
talking about is the fact that the
leader of the Scottish conservatives
believes that the people of Scotland
should return labor party members of
parliament to this house rather than
Scottish national party members to this
house it wasn't the message to the
people of Scotland quite clear don't
give the Tories what they want
Mr Speaker actually the the Scottish
conservatives deserve enormous praise
for forcing for forcing actually for
forcing the SMP into abandoning their
completely unworkable fundamentally
flawed deposit return scheme Mr Speaker
[Applause]
SMP you turned and listened to the
voices of the Scottish conservatives and
to business and we look forward to
working with them on delivering
something that actually works to deliver
for the people of Scotland and that's
just it Mr Speaker because if they can't
fix the mess that Nicola sturgeon left
their party in how can they possibly fix
the mess that she left Scotland in
yes
Mr Speaker it seems it seems clear that
the junior doctors strike is causing
serious risk of loss of life and
certainly causing harm and pain to
thousands of our constituents
the first line of Hippocratic Oath is
first Do no harm
when does the Prime Minister think the
BMA abandoned this Central tenet of
their profession
well Mr Speaker I thank my honorable
friend for this question we value the
work of Junior doctors and are Keen to
find a fair and reasonable settlement
which recognizes their role and The
Wider economic context facing the UK his
right to highlight the impact on patient
safety and that's why this government
has brought forward minimum safety
legislation to ensure that patients can
rely on a core level of emergency
service to protect vital patient care
that's something that we on this side of
the house support that I know is not
something that's supported by the party
opposite Ed David
speaker tooth decay
number one reason
four end up in hospital
regular Dental checkups could prevent
that but too many parents can't get one
for their child
in the East Riding of Yorkshire there
are now almost 3 000 people per NHS
dentist in places like herefordshire and
Norfolk fewer than two in five children
were seen by a dentist in the past year
this is a scandal Mr Speaker so will the
Prime Minister take up the liberal
Democrat plan to end this crisis and
make sure people can get an NHS dentist
when they need one
well Mr Speaker the NHS recently
reformed Dentistry contracts which will
improve access for patients Dentistry
receives about three billion pounds a
year there are around 500 more dentists
delivering care in the NHS last year
than the year before he mentioned
children I'm pleased to say there are
almost 45 percent more children saw an
NHS dentist in that year compared to the
year before I'm Marie Morris
thank you Mr Deputy speaker prime
minister's questions I'm on the 4th of
February 2015 David Cameron said he was
determined to do whatever it took to fix
the dawlish railway line the only route
to the Southwest
three is four risks losing part of its
agree funding while phase five false
foul of a 10-year moratorium on you
funding the line is only as resilient as
its wigist link will the Prime Minister
commit to getting this resilience
program back on track and fully funded
Mr Speaker we're committed to improving
the resilience of this iconic stretch of
Railway it provides a vital link to
people in the southwest that's why today
we've invested over 165 million pounds
in delivering solutions to protect the
line and I know Network rail is
continuing to develop the case for
further investment and my honorable
friend will be Keen to feed into that
law thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this
week my city of Dundee not only
announced its flights will be connecting
with Heathrow but also the Scottish
government's commitment to Dundee being
at the Forefront of making Scotland a
major world economy both bringing
investment jobs and opportunity however
the UK governments used to have a
problem with this
Mr Speaker Scotland's International
engagement is to be reduced despite
being paid for through Scotland's wealth
and taxes UK ambassadors and diplomats
have been instructed to obstruct the
Scottish government's International
engagement with every foreign Nation
worldwide told not to deal with the
Scottish government directly this Mr
Speaker has already been described as
night quotes smacking of a parent trying
and failing to control a teenager
so will the Prime Minister assured me in
the business days wealth creators and
most importantly my constituents that
want to see Dundee and Scotland Prosper
the wild Scotland short time left in
this unequal Union remains Scotland will
neither be put back in a box or will be
bending knee
I'm actually pleased to say that we all
support
Dundee they received 14 million pounds
in the leveling up fund to support green
transport Hub in the city center
demonstration of the UK government
wanting to invest in communities in
Scotland and deliver for Scottish people
thank you Mr Speaker
on Saturday I joined my 17 year old
constituent elephant board in walking to
raise funds for the national autistic
Society Alfie's mission is to walk 15
000 steps every day in the month of
April to raise awareness around autism
and to show that every autistic autistic
person deserves the best chance in life
this Saturday he's working walking from
Birmingham City Football Club to Edge
Western stadium and then back to
Birmingham City Football Club will the
Prime Minister join me in Wishing Alfie
the very best for his walk and his Noble
mission to change the way people think
about autism
can I start by praising Alfie for his
fantastic efforts he's an inspiration
not just to his community but to many
others and I wish him the best of luck
for Saturday uh our autism strategy sets
out our ambition to ensure that autistic
people across all parts of the country
get the support they need to live
fulfilling and happy lives and I look
forward to seeing Alfie's progress on
the rest of Israel do you want to see
McDonald
Mr Speaker my constituent Lisa and her
Civil Service colleagues have worked
tirelessly and with distinction during
some of the most challenging times but
she's fed up with ministers patting them
on the back all the while imposing
derisary two percent and now four and a
half percent pay Rises despite years of
peel the stream and no double digit
inflation she asked simply why should I
keep working for a UK government that
treats its workers with such contempt so
will the Prime Minister stop with the
myths and excuses and start negotiating
a fair deal with the unions
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I'll pay tribute to all our
hard-working public sector workers for
the job they do we have a
well-established independent peer review
body process for making sure that we can
have paid settlements that are fair and
affordable and I'm very pleased that we
reached agreement with many unions on
those pay settlements and I hope that
those members vote and supported them
thank you Mr Speaker would my right
honorable friend agree with me that
those who seek to criticize the
conservative record on Law and Order
should look in the mirror and ask the
question who was director of public
prosecutions for some of those years
well Mr Speaker my honorable friend is
absolutely right our record is clear
we've halved crime since 2010
neighborhood crime has fallen 25 just in
the last few years criminals are
spending longer in prison and crucially
we unlike the party opposite are giving
them the powers they need to tackle
violent protests Owen Thompson Mr
Speaker my elderly conception Ann has
been has been in Turkey for five weeks
now after her husband suffered a
devastating brain bleed and is now in
intensive care after their holiday
Insurance stay sure refuse to pay
medical bills and have so far refused to
engage with me this is resulted in and
being stuck with extortionate medical
bills and surgery costs which is covered
using their life savings the finance is
running out they're both stranded and
it'll be advised that they'll need to
find at least 50 000 pounds to pay for
an air ambulance to bring them home well
the Prime Minister meet with me to
consider all the possible options to
support constituents like Anne and her
husband in difficult situations like
this especially where insurance
companies abdicate all responsibility
[Music]
can I Thank The Honorable gentleman for
his question I'm very sorry to hear
about the case that he raises my
thoughts as I'm sure everyone's will be
with Anne and her husband at this
difficult time I will ensure that he
gets a meeting as soon as possible with
the relevant minister to discuss and
progress this case furthermore
thank you Mr Speaker can I take tell a
tale of two councils my constituents who
live in conservative control which Haven
District Council have enjoyed six years
of council tax freezes an excellent
Public Services while my constituents
who live in the Malvern Hills District
Council area which is run by a ragtag
bag of so-called Independence and greens
pay nearly 50 more in council tax for a
Bandy property
does the Prime Minister agree that the
best thing that my constituents can do
for the cost of living is to vote
conservative on the phone
my uh honorable friend is of course
right right across the country those in
conservative councils pay lower council
tax than those of the party opposite and
the choice at this election is clear
it's the conservatives that deliver for
you it's labor that costs you
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker this week the
women's rights Network published a
report by criminologist Professor Joe
Phoenix called when we are at our most
vulnerable revealing that between
January 2019 and October 2022 which
includes the pandemic lockdown of course
there are staggering
6539 reported rapes and sexual assaults
in UK hospital settings
that's an average of 33 incidents every
single week and as eight police police
forces did not provide any data the real
figures are bound to be significantly
higher what can the Prime Minister and
his government do to ensure that all
women staff and patients are safe in
briston's hospitals
yeah can I uh can I first of all say I
was deeply shocked like the right
honorable lady Anna Paul to hear about
the cases of sexual assault and abuse in
the NHS and I pay tribute to her for her
long-standing campaign on these issues
NHS organizations are responsible for
protecting their staff and patients from
sexual harassment and conduct they've
recently established a domestic abuse
and sexual violence program to build
route to build more robust safeguarding
processes for protecting patients we
will work very closely with them to
ensure that that is implemented and I
know she will hold us to account for
doing that sober baked thank you Mr
Speaker
on the 2nd of June Corwin station on the
van goghlin steam Railway will be
officially reopened having been closed
60 years ago under the beaching ax would
the Prime Minister join me in
congratulating the volunteers the local
community and the funders who have made
this possible and also take his own
share of the credit for granting the
leveling up fund to clue itself when he
was Chancellor which has paid for the
Magnificent new roof on Coreen station
well I I pay tribute to my honorable
friend for all his campaigning on this
I'm delighted that leveling up fund has
delivered for Corwin station it's a huge
boost to local ambition to see trains
returning there and I know that a small
team of the projects volunteers have
actually built the majority of the
station they deserve credit and indeed a
local company in wrexham they supplied
the new steel work for the canopy roof
providing a welcome boost to the local
economy and I look forward to seeing the
station open this summer
in my constituency to discuss food waste
but what struck me most was the
experience of shop workers on the front
line they told me they expect or to
suffer a violent assault every single
day they go to work so while more maths
might always be helpful what is this out
of touch Prime Minister doing to make
sure that people can be safe in their
workplace
well Mr Mr Speaker everyone deserves um
to be safe in their workplace and that's
why we're making sure that through our
sentencing act we have appropriate
sentencing in place for that and more
generally and making sure that there are
police officers and Community Support
officers across the country to help
combat crime uh we'll have to look at
Future sentencing when we look at
reviews of that case great uh thank you
Mr Speaker leadership and teamwork
deliver Bolton Wanderers superb four-nil
victory in the Papa John's trophy at
Wembley uh it's delivering the uh Bolton
College of medical sciences and
delivered Ayo Patel superb run worth
by-election Victory so what message does
my right-handed friend have for
councilor Patel and all the campaigners
Candence and activists as we run into
this Festival of democracy our local
elections
Mr Speaker can I share in my
arms for all those in Bolton but also my
commiserations to those in Plymouth
especially especially actually our party
chairman who's an avid supporter of the
green army but most of importantly I
welcome the election of council
councilor Patel and I look forward to
him joining our other councilors in
delivering for their local areas with
less crime lower council tax and
importantly filling more potholes oh
that's the car Michael thank you Mr
Speaker last week the home office
announced that they would not be setting
up a bespoke Visa scheme for the fishing
industry of the sort that is already
available for people working in fish
farms and an offshore wind farms they
also told Skippers that coup previously
employed by them under a temporary
scheme had to stop working immediately
as a consequence of that announcement in
fishing ports around the coast today
many fishing boats are tied up unable to
go to Sea it's the only time that Home
Secretary has been successful in our
state of ambition of stopping the boys
the Prime Minister and his party
promised our fishermen a sea of
opportunity if they would support me but
what what's the point of a sea of
opportunity if you can't get through to
fishing yeah well Mr Mr Speaker I'm not
sure I recognize the characterization
characterization that The Honorable
gentleman put forward we are proud
champions of the UK's fishing industry
not least with our 100 million pound
investment in fishing communities but
when we're always looking to engage with
them to make sure that they get the
support they need crucially all the
opportunities that are there for them
because of brexit we're keen to make
sure that we deliver
[Applause]
when the Prime Minister joined me in
thanking Lorna and Shirley of the Marios
tonenta Center and local churches in
Loughborough for all their hard work in
establishing a community allotment local
people use the facility as a great place
to get Outdoors as well as a relaxing
place to be
yeah oh Mr Speaker can I pay tribute to
Lorna and Shirley for all their
fantastic work allotments can do wonders
not just for as you said providing food
but also well-being and a place of
sanctuary for people around the country
and they deserve enormous pray for
creating one for the benefit of their
community at complete prime minister's
questions
thank you
well at the end of prime minister's
questions quite a bust exchange between
the Prime Minister and leader of the
opposition uh lots of other MPS getting
their questions in as well today first
prime minister's questions we've had in
a short while because there's been the
break over the Easter time let's bring
in our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates is here with me now to analyze it
um in in terms of of what we heard what
stood out for you was the last one of
the last ones before the local elections
they're in a couple of weeks time and so
those are always more rambunctious
they're always louder and more
aggressive
um today's premises questions sort of
could have gone either way really that
there are reasons why it's more
difficult perhaps for Rishi sunak he's
had a very good run through you know
this
um uh the first few months of this year
and I think even this political
opponents would acknowledge that but
there are some things on the turn
there's a return to strikes there is uh
the question what happened to Dominic
Rob is very interestingly saying
alongside where she's doing that today
uh you've got inflation running at above
10 food inflation and toilets into lots
of reasons why today might have been
tricky but my sense is though I don't
think the Tories will have gone away
from that particularly unhappy and I
think for me rather than delving
particularly into the detail of what
happened actually it was the question of
the contrast between the way in which
the two men kissed Dharma Richardson um
attacked one another personality the
gloves that comes off personally but but
if we could just listen to the two bits
where they attack one another back to
back I think we can hear that now
are the primers to see that because
they've lost control of the Court
service because they've created the
largest Court backlog on record yes he's
letting violent criminals go free
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker here's record
we're cracking down on grooming gangs
and he's
[Applause]
he's Mr Speaker
toughened the law on sex offenders so
they spend longer in prison he voted
against it Mr Speaker
we've increased rape convictions by over
60 percent meanwhile he meanwhile he he
attended he attended 21 sentencing
Council meetings that watered down
punishments
that's why they call him sir softy soft
on crime soft on criminals
and what you heard the Prime Minister do
there was go very personally for kirst
Armor's record as director of public
prosecutions which he was through the
2010s now that has been his record in
that period an absolutely key part of
the labor leaders Armory it's what he
points to quite regularly uh in speeches
and in premises questions there's a
reason to trust him because he ran this
big organization and was tough on crime
at the time so it looks as if there is
now a departure on Tory tactics where
they're going quite hard and quite
savagely about his record point you do
all sorts of things uh from from that
period whether it's his pension but but
more particularly uh his record they've
dug up uh some quotes from Emily
Thornbury uh who obviously now uh in
case Thomas front bench criticizing the
DPP at the time uh and it looks like
they're going from uh for him quite
personally and I think the question that
comes out of today's prime minister's
pmqs is when
is prepared to respond with the same
amount of political well really savagery
brutality now a lot of viewers might not
like the fact that it gets quite
personal gets quite nasty
um but I think that often to make an
impact cut through to land to lend a
bruise you do have to go just that
little bit further and and
I was really struck by something that
KIA stalma said in his attacks that he
he returned to the subject of strikes
and he tiptoed towards something which
could be really very toxic indeed he
said at the Prime Minister maybe he does
not use the same Public Services as the
rest of this that's maybe why he he and
some of his colleagues Greg hands at the
weekend think that public services uh
are going well when others don't but
that phrase again maybe he doesn't use
the same Public Services as the rest of
it could it be could it be that the
leader of the opposition was actually
referring to the prime minister's
children who we understand are at
private school at boarding school could
it be a reference to the fact that uh
the Prime Minister himself has admitted
in the past to using Private health care
well it might be but we don't know
because he didn't quite dare go there
is kirst armor brave enough is he Savage
enough is he brutal enough has he got
enough fight in him for this that's the
question tall he's really want to ask at
the moment indeed Sam thanks very much
for taking us to all of that